Portugal has become the vacation
destination last year more than 15
million people visited and this year
experts predict a 33 increase in tourism
while that's helped the economy of one
of the poorest countries in Western
Europe it's also pushing the poor out of
their homes
each time I wake up I think is this the
day I leave or stay it's really sad
because with my salary I can't afford a
house on my own Georgina samalis is
being evicted
like half of the Portuguese population
she earned less than one thousand sixty
dollars a month last year
tourists in need of short-term rentals
and foreign investors have contributed
to Soaring rents and housing prices and
increased mortgage rates
in Lisbon a Grassroots organization is
fighting to ensure people have access to
affordable housing
the fundamental things are to stop all
incentives creating premium markets for
wealthy people that come to invest in
real estate in Portugal to regulate and
control rents to lower rents which is
key and to stop evictions if there are
no suitable housing alternatives
the government is proposing a number of
measures including capping rent
increases lowering taxes for people who
signed permanent rental contracts and
increasing them for those who opt for a
short-term one it's also considering
ending its popular golden Visa program
for wealthy non-europeans that helped
bring in investment
critics say the government is sending a
dangerous message that foreign
investment is no longer welcome
includes we want to believe that the
government does not want to ruin the
country because to cool the main sector
of the economy is to ruin the country
while the Portuguese government
determines how best to balance the need
for affordable housing and foreign
investment evictions could continue
forcing more people into Shanty towns
like this
Natasha gname Al Jazeera